first of all thank you everyone for
joining us today i am so pleased to be
here
uh you're actually standing at my alma
mater
to elementary school here from
kindergarten through fifth grade
and it was one of the reasons why i
wanted to to come back and
see how the students and the staff
and the incredible folks are working
together throughout the state and the
county
working with our students so let me just
say first of all i want to
just thank the teachers and the students
here today and the staff
it's tremendous what they have done
through this pandemic and i know it's
been a challenging time
for everyone in nevada and across the
country really
we've come we've come far but we have
ground
breaking vaccines now we're rolling them
out quickly
fairly that will get us the pathway to
recover across
our state since the start of the
pandemic
my focus has been on addressing the twin
health and economic crisis that have hit
the silver state
and getting our kids back in school has
been a top priority
i know how urgent that need to reopen
has been both here and really across the
country
that's why i was proud to vote for
and fight for the american rescue plan
the plan
includes robust funding for school
reopening to protect our students
families teachers and staff today i
am proud to announce that in total we
are delivering
more than one billion dollars to
nevada's k-12 schools for coveted relief
in addition there is 92 million for
nevada to support covet 19
screening and testing and the american
rescue plan also provides
more money for closing the digital
divide
something we've been working to do since
the crisis started
i have heard from nevadans from children
from uh parents our teachers about the
challenges of educating our kids in the
middle of a pandemic
and i am focused on making sure that
our kids can heal from this pandemic
which has taken a
huge toll on them and i was just talking
with the principal here and the
superintendent
um mental health related er visits among
children rose 44
last year and clark county has been hit
hard with far too many experiencing
trauma and even
dying by suicide i i will tell you
this is a concern of not just mine but
many of my colleagues
in the senate right now and we are in
recess but when i head back
we are going to be having hearings as of
a subcommittee
for senate finance on the mental health
impact of
our students across the country
including what we saw here in clark
county with
the unfortunate horrific suicides of
some of our students
but i do know this as we continue to
look at and understand what is happening
here and address the issue
the american rescue plan was important
for us to put
dollars in there to support mental
health
needs for our students for young adults
and for adults across this country in
the american rescue plan it provides
more support
funding for counselors and behavioral
health experts
in our schools i am also working to
help students get access to peer
counseling which we have seen has been
so effective
across the country i also have a
proposal
to expand mental health coverage across
the continuum of care
i know here in nevada in the 90s we just
cut and got mental health and we never
even caught up
and now with the pandemic we're seeing
even more stressors
on our children and our families in
general
so it was important for me to really
actually focus on
behavioral health and substance abuse
putting more resources behind that
understanding what we can do more for
that continuum of care
and how we fund it and so that will be
part of the work that i am doing over
the next two years in congress
through the various committees that i
sit on just
yesterday i reached out to the biden
administration
really sent a letter to both secretary
of education and secretary
of health and human services to not only
make sure they understand that we have
funding in the american rescue plan
to address the needs of our students in
mental health and behavioral health
but we got we have to make sure the
money gets into our communities
and we can't work in silos anymore what
i want to see
at the federal level is for all of those
federal agencies that have some role
in the funding or the oversight for the
money that needs to come into our
schools
working together collaboratively so that
was the impetus of
my letter going to both the secretary of
education
as well as the secretary of health and
human services let me just say finally i
am so pleased to be back here
and have the ability over this course of
this last year during this pandemic
to really meet with through zoom
or through the video virtual interface
with so many students across the state
who have been challenged for for
different reasons but
it's something we have to recognize is
happening and so as we get them back in
school we need to make sure they have
the long-term care that they're going to
need whether it's in the form of
counselors
or social workers you know doris hancock
has counsellor and two social workers on
staff here and just talking with the
social workers even during the pandemic
they were actually going to visit their
students at their homes
i mean that's the kind of care that i
believe our parents and our community
want and that's what's been provided
through some of our schools but we have
to continue to fund it we have to
continue to make sure they have the
resources that they need
and i know just talking to the principal
here principal payne that
there obviously there needs to be more
resources so i will continue working
with our state superintendent
and dr jarrah along with all of the
other superintendents across the state
to make sure at a federal level we're
doing everything we can
to support our schools here our staff
our teachers
our students most importantly in doing
right by them so right now i would like
to
introduce superintendent ebert to say a
few words as well
good afternoon i am honored to be here
with all of you today
to address the importance of the federal
relief
fund that we have in particular the
american rescue plan
for nevada's students and schools
i want to thank senator cortez mastos
for her leadership and responsiveness
during the entire time of covid19 and i
also want to recognize the senator's
focus and she said it so well
on the social emotional learning and
support for our children
for our staff members for the community
as a whole
covet 19 we know has been a huge turning
point in education
and now is the moment that we need to
make sure that every single
child is engaged as well as every single
family
at every level of our public education
system
we must be responsible for the effect of
its actions and the ability to promote a
free
and just and prosperous education
one that strives to maximize the talent
that every single child brings to the
classroom
and thanks to the american rescue plan
our districts and schools will have the
funding
and the flexibility the funding and the
flexibility
they need to expand equitable access to
high quality learning opportunities
i'm proud to say that nevada has been a
leader in this way
at 15 out of our 17 school districts
had some form of face-to-face learning
since school started back in august we
know here in clark county march first
was a great day
was able to visit classrooms with
superintendent jara and then also this
week bringing back
many more students so they can be
engaged in a face-to-face environment
i'm extremely thankful and
great gratitude to the leadership like
miss payne here at hancock
i'm enormously thankful also to the
determination and ingenuity of our
educators
what we heard walking this campus and
what i've heard across the entire state
throughout this
school year is ingenuity and how people
have been changing the education system
and truly working for every single
child and identifying their unique needs
nevadans we have always shown resilience
in many many ways and
we've come together through this crisis
one of the things that you have all have
highlighted and thank you
is the connecting kids we are
the only state in the nation that has
provided a device
and has connectivity for every child
that's learning at a distance
and that is huge and if you hear of one
child please make sure we know because
we worked extremely hard with public
private partnership we've used the
federal dollars that have been
made available to make sure that our
children
are connected that we see them that
they're engaged in their learning
i guess also too huge kudos
to governor sisilak right away in
determining the playbook for
vaccinations our educators were at the
top
and so today as we all stand here we
know that now we're as a state and 16
year olds
but early back in late december and then
throughout the rest of the school year
educators bus drivers our food service
workers have had access to vaccines and
we have 100 percent
that have access to it
i guess despite all of our successes
that i always like to celebrate
we're moving from response and recovery
to renewal renewal in education
and the districts have this opportunity
now to revisit their strategic plans for
educating all of our students they'll be
working
on equity and making sure that they're
closing achievement gaps
they'll be working with their community
to make those determinations
bringing families in the public-private
partnerships that i spoke to earlier
it's not just a one-and-done we will
continue those partnerships out into the
future to build
a strong nevada and our education system
we know
we've come a long way in a relatively
short period of time
the tools and skills that our children
have brought
with them and expanded in the last few
months will continue
again i want to thank our federal
delegation as a whole and senator
cortez masto for investing in our
children we at nevada department of
education stand ready to work with all
of our
superintendents across the state and
thank you for being here today
oh now i have the pleasure of
introducing your own
superintendent superintendent hey jesus
jarrah
thank you superintendent ebert um i'll
be brief
um you guys saw me yesterday um and and
and really i can't thank enough our
senator senator cortez master an entire
delegation
um the state superintendent for her
leadership the governor's office
this is really i've said it all along
this is a community that just
wrapped their arms around their children
what we've seen
when we closed our schools connecting
kids
as a superintendent ebert mentioned the
only state
in the country that has connected all
kids that need a device that is a public
private partnership
we've done a great job gone to a
humanitarian effort our food service
department our food service staff over
11 million meals
feeding our families our social workers
our entire 42 thousand employees here in
clark county
have really done an amazing job and i'm
amazed
every single day when i walk into
classrooms whether it's virtually for
the past
six months to now the exciting as i'm
listening to our children
in the back it's so exciting to be back
in school and principal payne
and her staff are really really showing
amazing work in our buildings in our
schools
i'm going to tell you this will continue
the american recovery act
we're excited really to put
some things moving forward to address
the equity gaps that we've had in this
community
but i'm going to tell you our priority
is really to continue the work to serve
all children here in clark county school
district
to a high quality education and and
really
appreciate senator cortez masto's
leadership
um around the mental health aspect i've
been vocal about it
because our families and our children
are struggling
and due to the federal dollars that we
are receiving we're going to be able to
provide
many resources for our students who are
in crisis
and this is going to be a long term
goal for us as we move forward because
if they're not safe
they can't learn and that is a priority
for me for this community and for my
school board as well so thank you for
being here
thank you to our senator the federal
delegation state superintendent
and our governor as well for their
leadership in helping us
open our schools face-to-face
this week thank you so
[Music]
correct me if much wrong where is that
money exactly going to be going
towards i've been hearing a lot of it
maybe going towards professional
development
is that true and how much of it may be
going towards students and for what
so there's a lot of um
things that we're looking to address
obviously the digital divide is
something that we have to continue
moving forward
uh the mental health is a priority not
only for me for the board
for our community we're getting ready as
as we continue to review
the guidelines we're going to have
community engagement conversations we
have to have some
i appreciate the accountability that the
federal government has put in place
to make sure that the money goes to kids
to support our
students and our families and our
employees um so these are community
engagement conversations that we're
gonna come
we're gonna start having so we can
prioritize with the board
um for our children anything about
professional development
obviously you know as our teachers have
done an amazing job moving into distance
education
but we have a lot of work to do to make
sure that
18 000 educators have the resources
available for
professional learning to make sure that
they deliver high quality instruction
i i have i don't have the numbers yet
i'm glad kirsten
christina no it's it's it's around that
um that amount uh we're still waiting
and
having those discussions at this time
with the state and with the federal
government once the money comes
we'll get that we already have the
systems that we're putting in place for
accountability
so we can put them in the right place
it's about it's a little bit over 800
million right now for clark county
addressing mental health uh what what
are our numbers right now with students
suicides and
have the programs you had in place like
the winter fall yeah
i'm going to tell you the the universal
screener the panorama server that we've
used
has been well received and has been
implemented across all schools we also
have the lifeline project
program in 11 schools 68 schools they're
now utilizing again that's when we have
our multi-leadership
teams in our schools we're bringing our
students in for support that was before
our beacon and goal guardian where we
alert our
educators our social workers to contact
students at one of the social workers
that i was here
today he said he's part of that program
where it's 24 7
where our kids are if they're showing
some signs
of stress that we have adults going out
to reach out to them so
has it worked i mean i think it's it's
really providing a resources
resource for our families and for our
students
though the number of student suicide i
don't have that number we can get that
to you
so we've seen a much
at the stronger level but not quite so
much in middle and high schools
what do you think the effects of that
will be on things like graduation rates
interest in summer school
effects next year so as far as secondary
schools what we have seen across the
country i sit on on a covert task force
on the national cover task force with
colleagues across the nation
and that's why we've seen that in our
secondary schools it's a decrease in
enrollment of kids coming into school
obviously it's a little bit more of a
challenge
on the five days and hybrid so there's
there could be a lot of variables
uh that addresses uh that's impacting
that
um so our focus right now is making sure
that our kids
are getting the credits they need to
graduate
and and then obviously you due to the
federal dollars that we're getting we're
going to be providing some
summer accelerated programs as well that
is going to be k12
we're working on those plans right now
we're with our bargaining units
addressing those issues
uh so we can make sure that we
compensate our educators
but the appropriate rate so they can
come into work
yeah this is really off topic but happy
to talk to you about it
um it is going to be coming before us
right now it's just been heard in
a senate rules committee i am not on
senate rules committee but i understand
they had
an incredible hearing it's going to be
marked up when we get back a recess
and then voted on committee we'll see
how the votes break and committee
and then it will be coming to the floor
of the senate
i absolutely support making sure that
everyone in this country has the ability
to vote
that nobody's discriminated against
we're not gerrymandering
people out that everybody can vote
fairly
and i support the provisions in the bill
that ensure that there's transparency
and accountability
around not only ensuring the integrity
of our voting processes
but at the same time making sure that
billionaires can't buy elections
that individuals that are out there that
are advocating on a policy or for
individuals
shouldn't stay hidden that the
individual and voters should know
when they're getting information whether
it's a commercial on tv or social media
or something that's mailed to them
that they know where this is coming from
so they can judge for themselves
on how they are going to vote for the
individual candidates here's what i
truly
also believe and this came from senator
really senator warnock who said this he
said
it should be voters choose their
candidates
candidates shouldn't be able to choose
their voters and so there shouldn't be
this restriction to individuals having
the ability to vote we shouldn't be
putting processes in place
i think nevada has done an incredible
job and very proud
of the work that we did over the last
election cycle and
before particularly during the middle of
a pandemic to make sure
everybody had the ability to vote our
voting was secure
it was fair and it really is a model
here in nevada
for the rest of the country that model
is is what is in this bill
making sure that everybody can fairly
get out and have the ability to vote
and lastly senator we heard
superintendent say a few ideas what he
may want to do with the money what do
you specifically want to see with the
clark county school district
but we do receive i think it is
important for us at the federal level we
are not going to dictate we are not the
experts
what we should be doing is supporting
getting the funds into our schools where
it is needed most
and then talking with our state and
local officials talking with the
with the associations talking with the
parents and the staff
about what's needed in our community
because each community is going to be
different every school district in the
state
is going to be different and so we
should be flexible enough but we need to
make sure that the money
gets to where we have appropriated for
the reasons that why we appropriate it
one of the areas as you've heard me talk
about is ensuring that
we are taking care of the well-being of
our children
during the middle of a pandemic which we
don't know the impact it's going to have
we've already seen some of it
so you will see not only in the curtain
rescue plan
but in the other appropriation that
we're looking at doing even in an
infrastructure plan that is coming
forward
more ensuring that our kids are there is
no digital divide
i mean this is my elementary school i
can tell you when i came here
there was no internet there were no
tablets there was nothing like that and
but the building's still here
so we have to make sure that we are
providing them the resources they need
to improve it
upgrade it so no no child is left behind
in that digital divide that will be
important in our next
infrastructure package and i actually
have a bill that supports
funding to improve and repair our
schools across this country
so that the money that we put in the
american rescue plan can go towards
issues that are necessary to address the
well-being and the needs of our students
and staff
and at the same time we'll have a
separate infrastructure package to
address the infrastructure needs of our
schools whether that's even improving
the hvac or systems that are necessary
in some of our older schools i think
it's so important
thank you everyone appreciate you coming
out